all right I'm excited to welcome our
next speaker venue here from Berkeley
who is going to talk about stability and
convergence trade-offs of iterative
optimization efforts thank you I'd like
to thank the organizers for having me
and this is John work with Junsu Chen
and Chu team both sitting there so I
want to first give you a little bit
context of why we end up with this
project so Michael has been doing a lot
of data scientific research and
data-driven discoveries and I have been
going around for the last two years
really advocating three principles for
data science predictability stability
and computability and profitability and
computability by much already embedded
in machine learning and stability I see
it as a way to bring back statistical
inference and also just for interpreted
here and scientific reproducibility so
this is a picture you know my pokey
making with my student Rebecca barter
try to really make stability kind of the
roots of data analysis and with
comparability as the trunk and
prediction and other data results and
with the soil as data so my uncle to
stability is actually very applied and
it's really I think it's very very
fundamental for data-driven knowledge
discovery and if I really want to be
high bro I have a quote from Plato the
stability of knowledge so this is given
to me by a philosopher friend from North
distant so in this dialogue called Manno
plato was expressing his opinion that
that's why knowledge is priced higher
than crack opinion which can change and
knowledge differs from correct opinion
in being tied down so tie down I think
stable so this is self-evident about
five years ago I start working on
unifying stability from different
subjects and statistics and also dynamic
systems and numerical analysis it's
really a platform to integrate mridu
works in the literature and to develop
new masters and at a time there was a
lot of coverage of
discoveries it's really driven by the
need to do scientific reproducible
research and poor interpretation and now
we're moving forward actually it's
really very very useful for intervention
design so you have predictive analysis
you add stability and you won't have
targets for experiments to to carry out
so reduce the cost and searching all
over the place and we already heard
makes very nice overview talk that
stability now just in this mode
inaccurate stability results actually we
can go back to central limit theorem
it's very much one version of a central
limit theorem proof is the Lindenberg
spoking trick so you basically remove
and change my variable at a time and you
have some bound very much in spirit
that's what max was doing to proof under
the limiting Universal result for this
normalized ID random variables and if
you don't use Scotian random variable as
the replacement you can actually have OD
e and that characterize the distribution
has a unique solution which is normal
distribution this is the stability
technique is also much in the random
matrix results in high dimensions also
it's underneath it's a stability reason
so it's very fundamental for data
analysis and also we can see fundamental
for foundations of statistics so
stability principle try to unify say you
define your appropriate perturbation to
data and models and you define stability
measure and we see a lot it's like
perturb one that's called jackknife in
statistics you change one and data point
at a time and in practice we perturb by
cross-validation bootstrap and
subsampling and also want to unify
things Peter abuse group attribute they
have also data come from mechanistic
simulation data that's also a former
perturbation to data so it's really
trying to put it together and we do do a
lot of my I like harmony and instability
come from the practice and building
stability into a lot of predicting
acronym for this work we have stability
driven work for demand and biology to
figure out what are the pre organ
regions
using spatial gene expression and
patterns and this other work will be
adding stability to Lda
and so while we're ready so ridiculous
it's very much a component for my group
to solve real problems we have algorithm
we have domain knowledge and another bit
is actually practice driven theory so
while we're doing that it happens I
think Marez I think interviewed at
Berkeley and that's the work Mraz band
and Europe very much become a my radar
and then approach you and soon to start
on this project which is try to kill and
then and she joined later that this
ankle instability and computability I
use use convergence tree as a surrogate
if you really want to go by Turing
machine all that that's now quite
tractable so we try to really connect
this goose with stability and practical
compute ability to convergence rate and
there's equivalence made already
generalization so generalization average
not exactly as what I want in practice
yet which is good prediction but it's
close right because here generalization
area does that to you with the Bordeaux
buyers and in practice you really want
to have something on that so we're not
exactly there about the three components
they are ready so we're for the rest of
the talk we're going to try to push
forward this stability and convergence
lie on research to have a trade-off
between stability rate and convergence
rate and in some some we're returning to
a theme which already in basket and
Alice's paper they kind of alluded to
this variance impaired and bias
trade-off in in their paper and we kind
of return there with in the stability
framework and then we combine with
statistical minimax rate using account
spessard and bring in statistical lower
bound and combined have a new class of
algorithms and can talk about lower
bound of convergence and the last bit is
really try to do
our bouncy convergence uniform
convergence doesn't depend on the
iteration and can be quite inaccurate in
early beginning of iterative algorithm
power estimation so here are some
notations
I think I'm consistent with the notation
of the last speaker with s which is the
sample you have ID now you can see all
this analysis will be more challenged if
you remove the iid assumption right
we're really having very nice
mathematical structure here if you have
time series or something like a lot of
the devices have to changed and you have
population risk which is unknown are
sida instead of W I have C the last
lecture has W as the unknown I have
theta so switch and the empirical risk
which is known which is the training
error and as is the sample and we really
want to minimize or reduce the excessive
risk here it's like that can you do use
the data the best you can if you know
the Oracle theta 0 which is the closest
your family of models running to the
true distribution okay so hidden in
Caesar had as it's also iteration P
which I will bring it out sometimes but
usually keep that in mind so it's a
method with a particular iteration and
see that as Judah is actually the
empirical minimizer
and the last equation really tells you
it's pretty easy you a determine you
subtract a term you're a determined
subtraction and the last bit it's less
than equal to zero because you have ct2
de which is the empirical minimizer and
if you take the Oracle estimator on data
that will be higher than theta to the S
so that's lesson zero so therefore the
first term it's generalization error of
the later we'll show is bounded by
stability stability is really a positive
way of saying uh variance or uncertainty
and here we don't have to do is out to
error but it's never lies a measure of
change when you change the data and it's
already the most I think oh there's
probably form of complexity measure
which is the variance and this is like
you can think of this as a computational
variance because oh can a lot of
crunching moving data around which was
not conceivable fifty years ago to
calculate stability measure and the bias
is relative to the best Oracle model you
have so it's kind of I will say not
systematic bias but model bias relative
the best you can do we think the the
class of models you are entertaining so
very much it's this very inspired
trade-off which is very very important
for high dimensional statistics
oh and machine learning
so if you look at the first term
historically we already have ways to
upper bound on the generalization error
right the first is uniform convergence
pond actually I did my thesis like 30
years ago I'm doing this VC balance and
they're dependent data that was we call
empirical processes that's what's the
the name and they be polite at you you
know there was a lot of people doing
that and in nature we moved to read the
market complexity summer transition was
a key and then later on in the boosting
literature ptosis margin balanced by
Shapiro at all writing now I have a book
so that's another form of bounding the
generalization error and now we have a
career instability bound right in the
talk we have seen T or n for stochastic
gradient descent and also greedy in the
same place it was also in Maura's paper
already for that okay
and if we take what I did in two slides
ago and bring instability which have
been talked about earlier today
then we bound generalization by
stability and we bound the other term
are called bias by we call optimization
so we have this trade-off as upper bound
it's the accessories decomposition
we turned it around righted the other
way is the same inequality because we
somehow want to lower bound appear on
the right hand side we can follow the
most statistical thinking of minimax
like um Spencer to construct two
distributions which kind of the hardest
but the subproblem and you can have a
lower bound so you have three terms
right so the the right hand side term I
can DP into statistical minimax
literature and prove a lower bound
depends on the sample rate that had
nothing to do with the algorithm and
stability I have upper bound move it
around to the other side becomes a lower
bound with negative and then suddenly I
have our lower bound under optimization
term okay so for a particular example
you can show for convex moose laws the
lower bound is lacombe's measured by
constructing special distribution and
you can have well where square root and
as the rate
and we are interested in the trade-off
of the two terms as a function both T
and N
so in addition to this trade-off we well
is I think we believe the first time to
be able to show some stability bound for
necessary or accelerated a gradient and
heavy ball method and there are kind of
second order method and I have a star
there because we need like even in the
quadratic case a piece by quadratic is
was quite delicate with our reading
lenses proved last night was like quite
heavy use of analytical results and you
can see that the stability upper bound
for the gradient descent and stochastic
gradient descent is linear in the number
of iterations and found Asterix our
gradient is T Square so stability is
less stable but also converges faster so
as a result you can take T equal to
square root the end for the top you get
optimal rate for estimation and you can
t take T equal to and to 1/4 you still
get the same rate so just like they
treat out differently and you adapt to
the problem by early stopping in
different ways okay so you can now say
which one is better at least in this
idealized situation but in practice
people like slower algorithms somehow
you have more asymptote kind of low
flight area so maybe data-driven measure
finding that early points probably more
stable when things move very very fast
seems good and stable so finding the
sweet spot might be more challenging but
in terms of strategy call rates they
both optimal just by choosing different
start stopping point
this ability bound is for the exact step
sizes that appear in this dress method
or is it no matter how you choose the
thing is the exact step size could be
that somehow you can make the step size
smaller this is the Manila
that's another lot of the bomb we're not
talking about a step size right that's
another you can make a surge argument to
say that how does that inclusive depends
on how that fast I'm sure you have
different you could have different
stability rates are great result
okay and the second thing I want talk
about is converting lower bound
posterior I already hinted to right so
you can show that for comics smooth
slots the convergence rate so you keep
the stable the rate of stability for
algorithm and put them into a same class
you can show that then the optimization
bound is lower bounded by well over s T
n so this saying something conceptually
very heuristic very make a lot of sense
it's stable acting like a non-commercial
fast here is example that you have a
lower bound as I showed you for the
particular case and you move the
stability upper bound as T over N to the
other side and if you choose s TM
properly you get a lower bound on the
optimization conversion rate so this is
related by now the same as earlier class
of algorithms in the literature right
the first order deterministic algorithm
in NamUs number Oski and you didn't they
basically you have access to the first
order information then for this class of
algorithm you can now converge faster
than certain rate in the Agora work they
have a stochastic version of that
because stochastic they have to put
constraints on the second moment of the
the gradient and we have is really a
stable algorithm we control the
stability of the class algorithm and
it's just a different way by looking at
the convergence rate and this is mostly
TISCO in some sense because you
stability is very much impairing parent
since the statistics and they for this
case they are the same right the
question is I don't think they always
they have to be the same depend on how
to set out the class but we didn't
descent right upper bound base is
already in the paper of
Laurie span and Urim and we also know a
convergence upper bound our lower bound
really say that for this new class of
algorithms we know that the convergence
rate cannot be faster by over T
and as I alluded to earlier we were able
to show for quadratic laws and peace by
courtesy laws no sir Excel a gradient
method and heavy ball method which fixed
moment parameter upper bound and putting
together we have this table so the two
red ones will be able to be new but
under the somewhat restricted condition
and the last function so you now from
statistical considerations yonder is
converging snowbound and you're putting
algorithms together from estimation
point of view instead of how they reach
to the first order information
so the last like message of my talk is
really now let's compare stability
versus uniform convergence upper bound
right so I kinda came to machine
learning the first paper actually I did
was with Peter Bowman with some biking
analyzing stability instability of
bagging we went into this more refined
empirical process result and showed that
begging is meaning like reducing
meirin's
so that was actually my first encounter
with machine learning and turned out to
be actually stability related because
the O'Brien really bridged statistics
with machine learning and kind of you
know way Burke he is so good with this
connection with Leo's vision with Peter
and generalize hire Michael Jordan 20
years ago that's why working at such a
tight a connection between machine
learning statistics so Leo is very
concerned with stability and reduced
ability by bagging and then I work on
boosting selling wispy turbulent and we
did a very special case showing that the
number steps when you increase the
number step for boosting your complexity
actually asymptotes that's exactly what
in the new work we can see is that in
the beginning is number of iterations
and then you you don't keep going up the
complexity you have to use now the
uniform convergence pound so we have two
ways to bounce this generalization error
and in the beginning think bytes are
from 0 a fix point you're not really
able to explore the whole space so your
complex is now really reflected by the
basic cost of the dimension you're
really in a very local situation and
uniform convergence but for the
large-scale problems
it's seem to be uniform convergence
bound has no T in there saying the
square root of the over N but the
stability release a said its T for
example gradient descent over and when T
is very small it's much much faster
so I just want to show you that this
bounds really capture what's going on in
some examples so so you should take this
plus as qualitative
the
because we actually in the plus
calculated using data the stability so
it's now the bound it's really the
spirit calculus to the definition and
also optimization with one run but you
can see that it's linear this is a log
steps and the purple is the Union phone
but it doesn't change and for
small-scale loaches regression problem
the generalization error is controlled
by the optimization so that's the main
concern you do want converge fast that's
what you do you know this statistical
general and in our models you really
basically like it to converge and then
you get a few information out and the
stability bound is more relevant but
it's not dominated so it doesn't matter
too much we're trying to use because
tell me about the optimization error and
you can see the nasa rough it's a
different rate of convergence when you
go to large scale problems as i was
alluded to earlier you're really in the
beginning exploring much smaller set of
the space so the uniform convergence but
it's just too
it's like too big and doesn't really
capture what's going on so when you look
at large scale of just regression
problem again you see that the high
sierra is the start like the seeker blue
for the first plot for chen gradient
descent and the other one is the
optimization error and because gradient
descent converges slowly with the like
iteration number we plotted they pretty
much follow each other but for faster
algorithm as natural accelerating even
with the iteration duration we showed
you they did partner waves so for this
case the uniform coverage and bias just
stay the same it's now sensitive to this
change since actually coming back now
and the stability bound is able to
follow qualitative this
turning back so for large scale objects
regression problems stability is sharper
and more indicated on the behavior the
test error as ours now just plotting
them together to see that the stability
measure this is not from from the
balancer article bonds from the
calculation but I can see that it's
linear and it's not exactly near because
the bound is exactly linear and this is
to show that the stability bound is able
to give you the sweet spot to early stop
even though might be a little early
because still upper bound on the
stability
so to summarize so our stability were
very much moated with the practice of
the group using stability adding
stability to prediction error prediction
error we use it as a goodness of fit and
we have been adding stability in a
variety of problem document
summarization genomics and neuroscience
and both data perturbation and model
perturbation and that led us to disturb
the stability result we presented here
relative to computation like computation
convergence rate we emphasize the
trade-off between stability and
convergence rate which is expected
especially relevant for large-scale
problems and we're able to get new
stability bounds for nasara excellent
gradient descent and have able measured
and their quadratic and piece by
quadratic loss function even there are
quite quite delicate already and we do
believe the stability bond can be used
in practice especially early for faster
algorithms you have to do all this as a
way of calculating complexity and we
still working on the final version of
paper we hope we'll be able to upload it
in two weeks thank you questions
actually had a question about the the
civility Bell finestra does it carry
over to just plain plain momentum when
you have just extra term some
coefficient it should I think so because
they're heavy bombers it's a fixed
momentum any choice with the momentum
coefficient we could still I think yeah
it's quite quite heavy we I mean as this
has been stopping us for so that's why
it's this the whole project in stock
stopped and eventually we suited and get
where we want it to be but it's time to
at least maybe other people can come in
and do the more general case that's kind
of so stuff like here and half on this
week's tag on this o year and a half I
was thinking about doing the momentum
analysis and young people can do it
enough we can apply the lower bond so
yeah
Radek and piece by quadratic but still
they're always only applies for
quadratic functions piecewise quadratic
a little bit
Raymond there was quite what's not
trivial
yes it's easy to yeah because you just
perturb the data that's what we use in
practice right we're me I think things
like that on top of cross validation but
you have to decide on your version of
all the static analysis is perturb one I
call jackknife but in practice we often
prefer more than that and we have I
think you can say rods have some earlier
zone we call ESC B it's a version adding
stability to cross validation so in
practice at scott devine jackknife
that's people actually traditionally
have used it was proposed in the forties
in statistics and people use it to
estimate variance and also bias so it's
kind of we had a parallel version of all
of the but not using a modern technology
in statistics and people did a look at
objects function they look at parameter
estimate
so we use that a lot in our groups like
a data-driven research but you have to
be careful about what version of
stability and loss you choose one things
that we like to circle back to the
motivation that hasn't happened yet
yeah see what this thread carries out
can help us to do the practice there's
easily a gap yeah
thank you
[Applause]